the Tranquility that blankets the
highlands of Western Panama can give way
to A peculiar sound
this Symphony of slurps is how coffee
Growers
Jr and Ellen fan a coffee importer from
China searched for the best tasting Brew
very interesting coffee is Juicy yes
it's very sweet yeah it's more like a
fruity juicy sweet cup like I got a
fruity notes like candy and like grapes
the unusual slurping noise they're all
making does have a purpose it actually
aerates the coffee and spreads it around
on the palate this is the latest
offering from Hartman's estate
in Spanish
one that he was all too eager to show us
more than 5 000 feet up
wow Mira
this is what's special he says it's
where Earth meets Heaven the altitude
and volcanic soil make it the perfect
place to grow Panama's famous Geisha
coffee
he points out that Panama is narrow
enough that breezes from both the
Pacific and the Caribbean graced these
slopes there's no place on earth like
this for you this is Magic Mike magical
Michael so much so that fan flew
thousands of miles to see it so it's
safe to say that there's no place on
Earth quite like this when it comes to
Growing this type of coffee yes I agree
like this varieto like Panamanian Geisha
is the best this is it yes you might
think the name Geisha comes from Japan
but it's a misspelling of gesha the
region of Ethiopia where this particular
Bean originates a misspelling that for
some reason stuck and Geisha might not
have taken root if it weren't for an
experiment by Price Peterson and his
family at Hacienda La Esmeralda they
noticed Geisha bushes could survive some
unfavorable weather that inclined us
even more like okay we had this Variety
in the seed beds we're trusting it let's
try it and we planted it
at the higher altitude that yielded a
coffee unlike any they tasted in 2004
they entered it into the best of Panama
competition it was no competition judges
International judges
that had been exposed to coffees around
the world fell in love with it and gave
it on the scoring above a 90. Daniel and
Rachel Peterson have been working to top
that ever since experimenting with
different varieties fermentations drying
methods you name it is all the coffee
we're looking at here already spoken for
it is here yes wow this year absolutely
The Limited Supply and meticulous
handling have fetched more than a
thousand dollars a pound for their most
valuable batch
the Petersons were nice enough to allow
even one with a self-admittedly
unsophisticated palette taking the
floral Aromas and taste the notes of
cherries and tropical fruit live bill
number three
uh this three is just a nice complex
coffee
all the way through
they share that Pride with many in the
nearby city of boquete which now adds
Geisha to the list of draws for tourists
says renowned Panamanian Chef Charlie
Collins business has increased it's been
very good for the community but it's
also been very good for panel and for
one of his Baristas Kenneth Duarte who
has learned the Fine Art of Brewing it
you say this coffee is open doors for
somebody who wants to grow their own
coffee yeah or become a world-renowned
barista yeah someone like you exactly
those are Ambitions yes that's something
you want to do yeah just remember that
though friendly the competition to grow
the next best cup is intense which
brings us back to finka Hartman
and the slurping
wow
Ellen fan just selected one of their
latest experiments as the best of this
batch his next Contender he also wanted
us to take in the Aromas in his
dehydration room where he lights up
wondering where these beans will go
to put our coffee before someone in
France he says in Italy a person in
Japan in Hong Kong it's a pleasure it
fills us with pride a pride that is
truly homegrown for CBS Saturday morning
Manuel pojorquez Panama